quel ballon utilisé les rires le verger
la france soir venu m'aider mais bon
s'il avait des facteurs mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a aimées des français françois
guay et bien fermé mais que vous
arrive-t-il aux enfants sous la portion
on peut dire que vous êtes le bienvenu
un bon jeu je dois porter cette caisse à
casimir mais elle est beaucoup trop
lourd pour moi
écoutez je vous aider à deux ça va aller
tout seul et à la tentation
vous savez pour sûr cette fois - louis
et c'est pour ça qu'il est important
centre et déposant là sur le banc alors
si on est aussi avec attention et voilà
au bonjour mes amis je viens de me
baigner dans la mer et je fais de mieux
en mieux la planche casimir au casimiro
factor c'est un tel sujet casimir voilà
une caisse pour toi et je te prie de
croire qu'elle n'est pas légère gêne en
facteur merci aller au kiosque de julie
et buvez une limonade de ma part ramé
trait sur ma note
mais ça ce n'est pas un refus casimir la
limonade après l'effort
c'est mon réconfort ou belle formule 1
veux tu qu'on s'y mettent à deux pour
rire taquet
non pourquoi deux tu peux très bien y
arriver tout ça toujours aussi courageux
que c'est par là et voila voila tu vois
où il ya une lettre une lettre pour toi
l'intérieur que zimbra voyant mon cher
casini je suis en exil au dièse un de
tes ongles très éloignées
sarlat il ya vraiment longtemps que je
ne l'avais pas vu celui là je viens de
prendre ma retraite je te donne tous mes
instruments de musique
je n'en ai plus besoin signé en usine
d'eau diez en moquez strass alors merci
on eysines d'audience je suis vraiment
très touché
qu'est ce que c'est exactement un homme
orchestra et bien c'est un musicien qui
joue de plusieurs instruments à la fois
et il arrive de jouer dans les rues de
donner des concerts comme tous les
musiciens et il apporte de la joie aux
passants c'est un personnage bien
sympathique
ah oui mais venez voir rien des
instruments vraiment très curieux je
connais leurs occasions
j'ai pas tout suivi très soul ou les
enfants ils vont sûrement aider les
enfants venus au four venez venez vibrer
oui
des trucs le nom d à ce que je vais vous
montrer d'accord alors écarté du bout du
banc comme ça je pourrais les pauses et
la très bien alors commençons par celui
ci ou ça
comment s'appelle-t-il groupe et c'est
toi qui as raison c'est pas une
trompette ses tacles héros par bon
valérie hains claro celui ci s'est pas
exactement un accordéon sais c'est un
bandonéon % c'est la même famille dans
les orchestres qui jouent des tangos
argentins qu'elle pose devant toi yat-il
encore très bien c'est un accord alto
ils ne me laissent pas c'est un petit
corps t1
c'est un temps pour rappel plus c'est
une flûte tient du la pause devant toi
ça ou c'est magnifique ce sont les
centrales très bien
les baguettes soit c'est un tambour
d'enfants et qui va pas avec ses
baguettes
y at il autre chose bonjour mes très
chers amis que vois-je des instruments
de cet art merveilleux qu un autre que
moi appelé il ya bien longtemps la
musique vous comptez monter un petit
orchestre les enfants vous venez d'avoir
une idée géniale monsieur liste en tant
que chacun de vous prennent un
instrument et vous allez jouer sous ma
direction
très bien alors vous êtes prêts oui ou
non
alors mesdames et messieurs le propre
orchestre de l'île aux enfants va
interpréter
[Musique]
et
que est pas
mais vraiment pas moins sûr c'est pas
comme si vous êtes des musiciens
déplorable je pense qu'une petite
répétition n'aurait pas été de trop
mon cher et 1000 si vous me permettez
votre partition est à l'envers
mais monsieur du snob
si je puis me permettre à mon tour vous
vous servez de votre instrument par le
mauvais morts vous êtes vraiment des
musiciens et amant tableau casimir c'est
facile de critiquer à notre place du
ferait pas mieux oui eh bien justement
je vais me mettre à votre classe mais
qui voulez vous allez voir on va s'gêner
[Musique]
tu es prêt à venir
chers amis l'homme orchestre casimir
sous la direction des maîtres françois
monsieur du snav emile campagne et
moi-même va vous interprétez promenades
en traîneau de leroy anderson ou du bois
va essayer alors attention casimir
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas tellement de mérite
quand on est aussi doué comme moi en
tout et ça s'il écoute et j'avoue mais à
part ça je dois donner un concert sur le
fort à un bon cadre mais il m'a qu'est
ce que tu as dans le dos dans le dos en
sait qu'en temps normal je ne parle pas
du temps doux mais du lecteur de
cassette que tu as suspendu dix dont
casimir dit et bien moqué nous c'est pas
toi qui jouait c'était ton lecteur de
cassettes huawei diallo
[Musique]